and I highly highly recommend this
because again
judgment and decision making is
the most important thing you can have
people are terrible at actually honing
that they always say oh yeah I learned a
lesson really what what was it did you
did you write down what you were
thinking then and what you've learned
since no like you know we put very
little effort into this
[Music]
so I have this list of questions that I
sell uh I have this document that I have
I think I might have shared this once
before but I call it the decision
register
where I basically write down every major
decision that I make and so for example
the very first one that I have in this
list is from when I was 18 years old it
says quit pre-bend and this was uh sorry
I was 20 21 years old so I'm I'm a
senior in college I'm pre-med I take the
MCAS but I decide not to go to med
school the most obvious obviously good
decision you've ever made so I then I
have the here's the call the worst
doctor excuse me the worst doctor I'm
like we could fix this the obvious way
but let's try something stick out your
tongue
we'll use that for your ACL
um all right so and then I have an X
column it says did it seem big in the
moment because one learning was a lot of
the biggest decisions didn't actually
seem big in the moment uh but turned out
to be an important decision
um
and then I basically have like kind of
the what was the one decisive reason why
so if I boil down like not a long list
of pros and cons like what's the one
thing that like the main reason I made
that decision
um and then outcome and lesson learned
and so
I'll give you another example
um
a decision sell to Twitch and not to
Facebook those are the two final
companies that we had given us good
offers that we turned out more money
from Facebook to take the twitch offer
did it seem big yeah felt big in the
moment why
because after six years of a startup I
was tired and Facebook was looking at us
like we were gonna save their kind of
gaming initiative you know they were
looking at us to like make make it
happen where I was like twitch has
already won I like you know I can just
cruise control when I'm here like let me
just go play for the winning team versus
trying to like take the underdog from
the bottom of the league to the top
um in terms of this industry and uh you
know then it's like you know one of the
Lessons Learned is you know I don't know
what the other side was so I know what I
got out of it but so I think it was a
good call I'm happy with the decision
but you never know and that's how a lot
of these decisions go
um so I have this decision registered
now a version of it would be uh like
there's a bunch of investment decisions
here you know like um
uh not buying ethereum and Bitcoin when
the smartest people I knew
literally working in my office were
doing it at the time didn't seem like a
big decision I just kind of overlooked
it I didn't even realize this was a big
decision I was making seemed weird I
just kind of laughed at something
because it seems strange rather than
leaning in and trying to understand why
why are you so excited about this and
like hmm
could I place a small tester BET right
so terrible decision bad call
um
you know and I didn't pay attention to a
signal which is what the nerds do on the
weekend we'll probably all do you know
in a few years and this is what the
Nerds were doing on the weekend back
then they were really interested in
cryptocurrencies
um okay so anyways I have this like
decision register now with it I have a
bunch of like questions that I ask when
I'm gonna make a decision let me pull
that doc up real quick and you've been
is this a running document that you've
had for 10 years
um no I started it
um like four or five years ago but I
back I tried to go back and figure out
like do I um and it's like a Google Docs
Google doc exactly and I highly highly
recommend this because again
judgment and decision making is
the most important thing you can have
people are terrible at actually honing
that they always say oh yeah I learned a
lesson really what what was it did you
did you write down what you were
thinking then and what you've learned
since no like you know we put very
little effort into this and so I I I've
I've basically realized one Edge one
source of alpha is to take a
disproportionate amount of time than
most people it doesn't even take that
much time right it's like you know a
couple hours twice a year but just doing
that exercise can improve my judgment at
a rate maybe two or three x what a
normal person's would would do and then
all of a sudden people are like man
uh you know how do you you know like
whatever where do you get this wisdom
from God Sean you're so good at you're
you're so wise yeah you're such a good
at decision making like those abs you
gotta do something yeah put it on me all
right so here's the decisions here's the
questions I asked for an investor here's
what I have to run through I say
um what is the decision explain why I'm
doing this in a tweet length so I have
to be able to explain why I'm doing the
decision in a tweet length uh what
alternatives did I consider did I
consider any alternatives
what am I feeling and I have some
options uh like extreme fear pessimism
neutral boredom fatigue greed extreme
greed fomo right like those those are
the things I could be feeling right now
uh how long have I been thinking about
this decision right is it a few hours
few days three weeks three months a few
years
who and what tipped me over the edge so
what is like kind of the last
conversation or podcast or thing I read
that like
made me make take action
um what are the secondary benefits of
this so like can I sleep better at night
because I'm not worried about a margin
call or something like that
um
if I took away all the secondary
benefits would I still make this
decision yes or no
what makes me think I'm right so I have
to write why do I think I'm right about
this what maybe what makes you think I
might be wrong
um
upside if I'm right downside if I'm
wrong so I have to define those two and
I say what follow-up decision should I
make to make this decision more
successful
um
and then how do you predict that this is
going to play out and I have to like
answer how I predict it's going to play
out and then I basically set a date it
says what date will you revisit this and
so I'll go revisit this um and so I did
this for when I sold all my stocks I
could go look at this right now and be
like was I right was I wrong do I do
what can I learn from how I was thinking
then so that the next time I can think
better basically about this like how
many decisions do you have that you've
documented this way I think I have done
this maybe four or five times now in the
last like you know two three years
you know like selling you it was one for
example
um
uh you know making a big financial
decision investing in
um you know a private company
um you know deciding to rent instead of
buy a house right now things like that
do you consult your wife when you do
these things as well
no I probably should she wishes I did
but I don't
know well not necessarily like asking
for permission but like getting your her
perspective yeah that's the problem I
want her perspective but I feel like uh
there's like this the messed up
psychology of me is like kind of turns
into asking for permission at some point
you know like you got to be aligned to
do this and like what if she's not a
line uh maybe I'll just do this which
she hates and how much decision or how
much like when you're selling the milk
road yeah you sold the last company I
think before you were married but when
you're selling the milk Road
um are you like hey just so you know
this is happening or is it like hey it's
happened no no I talked to her a bunch I
got her opinion on it
um and you know several times during the
process and uh you know she's very
helpful that
um it's more of the like stock or
startup Investments that I don't really
remember because I'm like man I'll have
to explain so much context because it's
not an area she pays attention to she
doesn't pay attention to the stock
market she never bought a stock in her
life she doesn't know about startup
investing Angel Investing or these
companies so I'm like oh man the context
for that is really hard but like
selling a decision to sell a company or
buy a company that's much easier to
explain right no I I consult my wife a
ton on this stuff but I I think it's
more so of like I just need to speak
this and uh like I need you to just like
be a brain a little bit like that that
character on billions the like the
office like uh Wendy yeah like mindset
coach or psychologist whatever I feel
like she's like Wendy
like her demeanor is like so even Keel
yeah she's called she's like I could see
her being
very like third party about it versus
saying like uh like I could see her
being like I'm gonna help you with this
decision versus like this is our
decision I'm gonna have my opinion
you're gonna have your opinion then
we're gonna figure out whose opinion is
Right totally
yes and I think that I have a history of
making emotional decisions and so I A
lot of times I need someone to be like
hey don't be crazy don't do this right
now just like sleep on it just wait just
wait
um dude the decision register is good I
think you should I think you're very
talented at these Frameworks I'm gonna
probably steal that for Hampton because
I think it's quite good so you have to
post it on the YouTube link so yeah I
can actually read it I do something
similar it's different this is more
organized I'll put it I'll put a link to
it in the description on the show notes
for YouTube and whatever and you can
just I'll just make it a template people
can make a copy of it for themselves
um
and that's on we'll we'll plug your
thing small boy is it dot Co or.com dot
Co yeah a boy spelled normal or like
baller boy not boy
small normal this is the smallboy.com uh
yeah dude that thing's growing like
crazy man we have like a hundred
thousand people on the list now and uh
it's amazing that's like in a very
shorter period short period of time
did you start at zero I started uh 40
38k I think
um when did you start it so I had 38k
from like your old email newsletter five
through Tuesday type of thing and then
basically at this
start of this year-ish like maybe
February or something six months ago
yeah maybe five six months ago started
any paid marketing uh yeah paid
marketing on
um a little bit of paid marketing you
know still I think half is like organic
or something like that so you know it's
like half organic growth half uh paid
growth there's newsletters man they're
the best yeah they're the best that I
take all the credit I take it 100 of the
credit I get one not your effort not
your day-to-day hard work it's all me of
just saying newsletters are cool exactly
um I'll take that I'll take 100
newsletters are awesome dude my my
decision register for why to start the
milk Road was like I think I know how to
do this because I watched Sam do this
like from scratch with the hustle and
like I think if you took the hustle plus
crypto that would work that was like you
know the whole thing is like pretty sure
hustle plus crypto would work secondary
benefits dude hustle plus anything will
work like just do the hustle Plus or as
you say it's like you're like the milk
Road of business and Tech news uh yeah
you know what's the hustle it's like the
milk road but for this thing
um but no the milk Road the hustle plus
anything it's it's all that will work
for the foreseeable feature I think
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
well you know what's funny I don't know
how much you get hit up by these people
who are doing newsletter businesses
probably all the time I ignore them you
ignore them I've learned to ignore him
because
my friend Ramin has this great little
framework he says which is every
business is hard it's just hard in one
of two places it's either hard zero to
one or it's hard one to end
and what he means by that is like it's
some business are really hard to get
started and get initial momentum and
then some businesses are really hard
like really easy to get initial momentum
but then turning that into a valuable
business
um that's like at scale is really hard
and I would say
because of this podcast people basically
see Sam did it newsletter Sean did it
with the newsletter I too will do you
know the AI version of this like you
know I'll do the whatever version of
this
newsletters are very easy zero to one
businesses they're not easy one to end
and as I've talked to people that are
doing this and they're asking for kind
of advice or whatever
I'm like talk to me in six months I told
one of the I I guess straight up I go
um
you're gonna drive this is driving off a
cliff you don't even realize it yet
um
and I was like he's like why and I was
like you know to explain this to you
we'll take like you know some time and
like explain what what I think you
should do instead
um
I don't really feel like coaching that
but uh I'm just gonna tell you like
please don't fall in love with this as
is because I'm telling you that this
isn't this isn't going to work this is
not the answer to making something
that's successful like because it's very
easy to see just the subscriber count
going up
um or like if you're in a hot space like
AI you'll get easy sponsorship revenue
for like you know the next six to 12
months
but like if you want to take this to the
Finish Line where this thing is spinning
off millions of dollars a year profit
and you're able to sell it for maybe
tens of millions of dollars which is
what all these people I think would
dream of doing
um
that's where the real skill comes in in
this and I think that as a lot of these
people I do not feel are equipped to do
that based on what I hear their plans
are the person who's done it best I
think is Austin Rafe for morning yes
it's um 10 years old now
um I think they publicly said that
revenue is in the 70 to 90 range I
forget exactly what they said publicly
but something like that
250 employees I forget I went to their
office dude he's got like a tech office
set up it's like a beautiful office like
he's done it all the right way where I
mean he's made a bunch of Errors just
like everyone but that they he's done
such a good job of having durability and
long-term View and also short-term like
moving quickly
that guy's a machine he's one of the
more impressive operators well the thing
is people see that they see the hustle
um and they see just like the tip of the
iceberg right it's like this Iceberg
Theory like when you see an iceberg in
the water you're only seeing you know
the top little bit you don't see the
giant ninety percent of the mass is
under the water the benefit for me with
milk Road was
I was there when you were doing just
events and then blogs and then you
pivoted to the newsletter we were in a
mastermind group so we're checking in
every month every month we would meet we
would talk about what's going on what
you're trying to do and so I got to
cease The Five-Year under the water like
build up
and I think most people don't have that
like that's a that's just luck basically
for me that I had that
um and that's why milk Road was able to
work a lot better than if I hadn't had
that most people don't have that they're
just trying to copy what they see on the
surface level and that'll get you kind
of the zero one I don't know if that's
going to get you the one to end I I
think for most people not I think if
you're a great entrepreneur you'll make
it work no matter what uh the problem is
you survey 10 entrepreneurs they all
think they're a great entrepreneur but
sort of by definition not everybody's
above average right like you get
um you know maybe one out of the 10r the
problem is all 10 think that they're
that one and uh you know that's gonna be
yeah they're challenging what they don't
see is that morning Brew at this point
the hustle I don't know how many
employees they have now but we don't
sell ads but with morning Brew in order
to make 70 or 80 million dollars a year
in Revenue you need 80 sales people and
if you have 80 sales people you also
need 30 like people to like handle the
stuff that they're selling
um you also need like Evergreen content
like you guys talk about what's going on
in general with General business
people who are doing these AI
newsletters right now they're like
here's the latest new demo in AI
guess what 18 months from now that
shit's not going to be interesting at
all to anybody and the advertisers are
going to realize that the type of person
who just wants to like see an AI demo is
not very valuable to advertise to
um milk road work because people who
read about crypto like what's going on
in crypto we're crypto investors crypto
investors are a very valuable audience
segment and that and so that was very
different than just like so crypto AI
they're all just topics right they're
all just the new thing no no because the
people who write about crypto were
putting tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands or millions of dollars into
those portfolios and we're a very
valuable customer that's not true with
an AI reader right but they don't see
that they just see the surface level
stuff they're not thinking about it
critically enough to realize that
they're just writing this like kind of
current momentum where every day there's
like a mind-blowing demo and people are
curious 18 months from now that that's
going to fatigue out that is not going
to be the case that and then and also
your Advertiser is going to realize that
like cool advertising yourself a random
guy who likes to see like you know the
cool stuff that AI could do that's not
translating into a lot of money because
that's not a very valuable uh audience
demo
um it's not going to work and you can't
be a mercenary about the content like a
lot of people are like oh I just hired
this person overseas and we use AI to
actually make the content and uh that's
really hard not impossible but it's hard
at the end of the day when you have a
newsletter you have to get someone to
act you have to say uh I am going to be
at this location at this time and if no
one shows up then your [__] sucks right
and getting people to do that is really
really really hard
um it's very challenging at the end of
the day it's about getting people to
take an action whether it's to buy
something to show up somewhere and
that's really [__] hard if you're a
mercenary versus a missionary right and
you're like all in on this [__] that's
why milk Road works because you said I
one of the coolest things you guys did
was I invested this much money into
crypto here's my portfolio you can see
it as we go I am yeah I'm in this [__]
and I'm going to talk about that and I
talked about the stuff that like each
day it was basically
what is the thing I'm most curious about
that was the only guiding principle it
wasn't like news it wasn't announcements
like if those were in the letter the
newsletter cool that's fine
but the lead story had to be the thing
that I thought was most interesting
which was sometimes Twitter drama which
was sometimes a cool product which is
sometimes a price analysis which was
something whatever and
um
that's very different than if you hire a
a journalist or an aggregator to
basically like
summarize headlines from from stuff and
so you know that worked for us I don't
think that's the only way to make it
work but uh it was one of the ways where
it felt very different and like you said
like if we said hey we're going to be
here at this time and date people would
cut people would come because they were
excited um and they were excited to meet
us they were excited to meet other
people that are like them and the brand
um you know had had some influence on
people which is what you need in order
to do this if you just throw up a quick
beehive newsletter and you get like you
know 12 000 subscribers and like you
know the number of subscribers is really
the wrong metric I guess that's the
other way of putting it
um people it's the easiest metric and
again the easiest metric is not the
right metric necessarily it's the
easiest metric to look at but I don't
think it's the right metric to look at
for
a newsletter
this is one of those episodes where we
talked about stuff that I personally
care about I could talk about this
newsletter crap forever I can talk about
personal finances forever this rate it
might be a high ratio of things we love
to talk about but maybe our audience
doesn't all entirely love but I'm very
eager to see the response to this
um I could talk about this stuff forever
this stuff actually interests me like
totally and by the way I think that's
the only way this podcast can work is uh
like I was watching this thing uh Joe
Rogan uh Joe Rogan doesn't go on very
many other podcasts but one of the ones
he goes on is like this breaking points
news thing that he likes um so they
interviewed him and they go they go Joe
you know like everybody does podcasting
everybody does interviews
not not everybody's having like what's
your like what you what you've created
with JRE like what are you doing
differently breaking points is awesome
yeah I know breaking points yeah uh
Sagar and I forgot what her name is uh
yeah the woman there too they're they're
good and so they uh and what do you say
at first he just tries to brush it off
he's like I don't know I don't like I
don't know
it's just like kind of like fake
humility but also like you think he's
trying to make a point which is it's not
some calculated thing and
um and then but the guy pushes he's like
but there must be something like whether
you know whether you planned it or you
intuitively do it like you agree there's
a difference between what you're doing
and what other people are doing and
there's a difference in the results
you're getting like just if you had to
think about it if you had to answer what
would you answer it's kind of kind of
pushing him and he goes he goes I think
that's the thing I don't have a like I
don't come in with this sort of like
plan or agenda
he goes look when I started this podcast
I didn't think anybody listened you
couldn't even tell if anybody was
listening and he's like so I just really
had nothing to lose and I just decided
to do it the way I wanted to do it so
like I just wanted like if I'm chilling
with my friends or we're smoking weed
and that's what the episode is great
because that's what I wanted to do if
I'm fascinated by this alien conspiracy
and I can talk to this scientist
great that's the conversation I want to
have everybody told me like this needs
to be one hour long it needs to be
shorter three hours is just too long
he's like but I didn't like how the
conversation was gonna be in an hour I
liked having the three-hour conversation
so that's what I did even though it like
you know broke the rule it wasn't like
audience driven he goes and so now yeah
he's like basically that's what was
working so I just decided not to change
it he's like basically I just this
podcast is a massive education for me I
have the conversations I want to have in
the way that I want to have it and um
you know I just don't do things that are
like lean into this the audience is
really responding to this he goes that's
how you end up like those late night
talk shows where everything is just fake
like the host is fake the interactions
are fake it's just like it's quote
unquote professional but it's the least
real thing and he's like I don't think
people like that actually he goes
podcasts are professionally
unprofessional and he goes uh he goes I
just don't read the comments and I don't
try to do things based on what the
ratings reviews are going to be he goes
I realize the only way for this to be
interesting was if I'm actually
interested in it you can't fake being
interested in it for very long it comes
through he's like so the only way to do
this is if I'm interested in it and then
I'm just the audience will be what it's
going to be at that point like it'll
just be the other people who are
interested in this and that's
sustainable for like kind of forever
um and I thought that that is it relates
to like um
uh Hassan minhaj he he said this thing
to me once he goes he goes I'm not he
goes I'm like why aren't you on Tick
Tock bro like why aren't you more on
Instagram like you could be killing it
dude these are growing I'm giving all
the logical reasons to be on he goes I
don't want to be on because I know to do
to win in those games you just have to
dance for the algorithm like whatever
the algorithm wants that's what you got
to do and he's like I just don't want to
do that I want to be an artist he goes
the best he's like I come from Comedy
and the best people who are the best
comedians
they um
they're free they just do what they want
and they are the judge they don't care
really like they pick up on signals from
how people react to it but like they are
the end decision maker of if something
was good or not and um he's like you see
this in everything he goes he goes I
love basketball you see it's on the
basketball court guys like Steph Curry
or Luca dances they're free they're just
playing how they want to play and that's
it they don't they're not like
overthinking it they don't they don't
they don't have this like voice in their
head that's constantly judging it and
thinking it they're actually free to
just create their art and he's like
that's what he's like that's like how
the best people operate and um Rogan
said the same thing about comedians he
goes if you watch Dave Chappelle he'll
do these shows in front of like 50
people
he's done shows in front of 50 000
people but he knows it for 50 people
he's having a great time he's having a
great time because he's out there
smoking a cigarette and chilling he's
just smoking a cigarette he's talking
he's not even doing planned material
he's like he's having a great time
because he just likes doing it this way
and that happens to have gotten him a
huge fan base and he's like that's kind
of my like if you want to say what's
your strategy he's like that's my
strategy and I think that that's just
like a more admirable way to approach
like content creation versus this like
um
I'm gonna just cater to this moving
Target of like what my audience what
what the audience wants
well there's a there's there's a way of
like not truly caring but then you also
like I like seeing our feedback we had a
guy message us and he's like someone
died in my family and I listened to you
guys a ton and that and I'm like oh
that's that's sick or they'll someone be
like man I love when you talked about
this I'm like that's awesome right I
feel good about that I want to make
people feel good as well while also
making myself be selfish and only
talking about what I want to talk about
but it there is a small motivation of it
feels good to make others feel good but
we don't like go crazy on that yeah yeah
yeah exactly and just who ultimately
who's in charge right like you might
have three co-founders in your business
But ultimately push who makes the
decision if push comes to shove
obviously you all talk about it you all
have a say
but if a decision needs to be made who
can who can make a final call in a tough
to sit tough spot and I think that's in
on the content side I think that who
makes the tough call in the end has to
be do you think it's good do you like it
are you interested in it all right
that's
that is the highest to me that's the
highest like order decision maker what
do you want to wrap here yeah let's wrap
it up all right we have a bunch of stuff
next week but that's the pod
[Music]
foreign